i continue to insist that the maga
cultists the trumpies
as joe biden called them
are yes
they are indoctrinated cultists but they
are dangerous as well here's just a
little bit of a sampling from the
pennsylvania rally here are mag
occultists chanting trump one
it's hard
it's hard to get through all this steve
i i just
yeah
just because you say something over and
over and over and over and over and over
again for two years
doesn't make it true
here's a guy who wants trump back i
think what this guy is saying is that
his parents would abuse him meaning this
guy's parents abused this guy
and thus
trump is similar and is good what they
say about donald trump they say that
he's mean and everything well you know
what when you're growing up it was your
father who kicked you your mother kicked
you in the ass to keep you on a
straightening hour and that's what he
does
i went on a leader i don't want a lamb
that's right a leader a leader not a
lamb we know yeah so that's really more
sad than anything else to be perfectly
honest here's one guy who just might be
drunk which is certainly no crime but if
you think it's tough to defend trump
while sober it's a lost cause when drunk
don't even try you should have folks all
the things the economy is it's
ridiculous and the way
these other people they want to change
the whole country they are changing it
they're ruining it what they're doing
donald gionee boy that can straighten it
out i'll tell you that
yeah so there is a gentleman expressing
his well thought out opinion here's a
woman who is wearing a trump one shirt
that's now a mainstay at the rallies
i believe that this woman says obama and
hillary should be in jail obama i want
to buy
and they stop it still you know stuff is
filled
she wants them to stop the steal right
away
we know who won and that's a joke one
but they they they're very cheating and
now why we do that why every i know come
for obama's house well if i know come
for about one
time
right why didn't the fbi come from for
obama and and hillary i think she's
asking which we know the answers to that
because there was nothing to come after
them for
becoming a messaging term why they do
that you know
yeah i hope to buy and we never get up
thank you so much yep so uh that was you
know another one of these delusional
declarations
here's a guy who was he's he was at the
rally he was also in washington dc on
january 6th and he says he was even
investigated by the fbi we were going to
come back the first saturday of every
month and give that they gave us not my
presence for four years we were going to
say not my president and have these
speeches every month like clockwork what
an embarrassment that would be so the
democrats had to pull the security and
let a riot happen and let somebody get
die
so they could stop these rallies so they
could say see trump rallies are
dangerous people get killed yeah who
gets killed we get killed
uh but also on top of that
the fbi when they came to my house they
wanted to know if i was plotting on
overthrowing the government
now what am i supposed to answer that oh
yeah i am actually yeah
all right so very common thing lots of
trump rallies have january 6th attendees
um
one other clip for you and this is more
sad than anything else here's a woman
who says she camped out for five days at
the trump rally to get the best seats i
mean this is this is sick
we've been here me and mike bowman's
been here since tuesday night tuesday
night you guys tuesday night today is
saturday that's tuesday wednesday
thursday
five days early to see president trump
wow
we've had a wonderful time and we can't
wait to see the president and show him
how much we when they say this
i i know that you refer to former
president still as mr president
but the way in which these people just
talk about we want to see the president
it really seems they think he's still
the president supporting
incredible mike how has the past five
nights been for you camping right here
to make sure that you get the front row
spot i mean what continues to encourage
you very sick people it isn't put that
much effort and money into this donald
trump i mean
we need him back and i'll do anything
you know to help the support for him
thank you so much and we've got some all
right and just an absolutely electric uh
speaker as you can see
imagine being this delusional so we have
a real sickness in this country and as
i've said before i don't know
how we educate ourselves out of this
stuff
i really don't
but i'm interested in hearing your
thoughts on how we do it
one of our sponsors today is feels feels
is a premium cbd designed to help you
feel your best delivered right to your
door with everything going on in our
daily lives we all need to take a moment
to relax and that's where feels comes in
many people report cbd helping with
anxiety stress and sleeplessness if you
have aches or pains there are people who
use cbd as a safe natural method for
relieving pain without side effects
feels cbd oil is awesome the cbd infused
mints are great they leave you with
fresh breath you can try feels caffeine
free focus melts to get you through the
afternoon slump feels even offers a free
hotline with experts to give you advice
about cbd dosage finding the right
starting point and when you join the
feels monthly membership you'll save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel at any time become a member
today get 50 percent off your first
order with free shipping when you go to
feels dot com slash david p
and use the code david p
the link is down below